[Music]
if you're a Disney Princess fan chances
are you've noticed some similarities
between your favorite princesses
we found some strange things that all
Disney Princesses have in common we
saved with the most perplexing
similarity for last believe it when we
say you'll be shaking your head when you
see it if you love Disney Princesses
like we do subscribe to our channel to
see our newest videos first and click
that like button now check out these 10
strange things all Disney Princesses
have in common they all wear blue you
may not have realized this but there is
a secret signature look that all Disney
Princesses have in common in addition to
their curious and hopeful spirits their
courage and their tenacity they also all
wear the color blue don't believe us
feel free to check it out for yourselves
we'll wait are you back now good so now
you know that Belle Princess Jasmine
Ariel Sleeping Beauty Snow White
Cinderella and of course Elsa elegantly
glide around singing their songs while
wearing blue dresses coincidence we
think not designer Christopher Kane
confirmed this similarity when he told
Elle magazine that when you think of
every Disney heroine they're all very
blue he said it's a thing Disney blue
Leatrice iseman of the Pantone color
Institute told Allure magazine that
female empowerment is the reason for
this color choice she said it's a very
subtle way of saying that young women
can be empowered to putting our favorite
princesses in blue goes against gender
conforming colors and proves that blues
not just for boys iseman also pointed
out that blue is the color of the sky
representing hope and positivity it's
always above us even if it gets bit
cloudy from time to time they all have
animal pals Ariel has founder jasmine
has Raja Mulan has Mu Shu Merida has
Angus Cinderella has her mice you get
the idea
in every Disney film the princesses rely
on the company of a trusted animal
sidekick to make them smile help them on
their missions
and sometimes get in a way the benefits
to having a friends from the animal
kingdom are plenty researchers say that
people with pets have less illness and
tend to be more content and happy than
people without pets let's face it those
mice and Cinderella were probably the
only things keeping her from going
completely
cuckoo come to think of it she was
talking to mice as if they were her
friends maybe she already lost one too
many marbles since Disney Princesses
usually have major hardships to overcome
it makes sense if they would buddy up
with a feathered or furry orphaned
sidekick even hey hey had his helpful
moments when he wasn't falling off the
boat plus those animals are just so darn
cute the angelic voice of a songbird if
there's one thing all Disney Princesses
have established it's at any time is the
right time to burst into a powerful song
whether it's Belle singing loudly about
how she is too good for the town she's
walking around in right in front of the
townspeople jeez Belle you know they can
hear you right or if it's a mermaid
singing about trinkets and treasures
underwater wait how is she seeking like
that underwater that really is a magical
voice but how is it that all the Disney
Princesses have such beautiful voices
seriously who is given these ladies
vocal lessons Christina Aguilera or
Jennifer Hudson these girls would crush
it as contestants on the voice this got
us wondering what would happen in a new
Disney movie if a beautiful princess in
a magical Wonderland opened up her
rosebud lips and belted out a tone-deaf
scratchy rendition of a hopeful Disney
song yeah we're pretty sure nobody would
want to watch that now it all makes
sense it really is a princess
prerequisite to have some stellar pipes
smart thinking Disney will take else's
advice and let it go for now unbeatable
odds stacked against them Disney
Princesses are these strongest folks on
the planet they have to deal with
insurmountable obstacles and face
incredibly difficult challenges any time
you think you're having a bad day try
putting yourself in their shoes oh did
you get a flat tire on your way to
school or work well Elsa was forced to
live by herself and hide her powers
before setting off an eternal winter in
her own Kingdom and banishing herself to
live on a snowy mountain where there was
no food or companionship feel better
good let's try again are you bummed
because you got a bad grade on your test
or didn't get that promotion
well mallanna's grandmother died all the
food on her Island turned into this
black ashy stuff she had to sail by
herself across the ocean when she
finally met up with an annoying arrogant
he abandoned her when the going got
tough then she had to face a giant lava
monster and she wasn't even scared now
that test at school doesn't seem so bad
does it
giant eyes have you ever wondered what
the eyes of Disney Princesses are so
disproportionately larger than the rest
of their faces
well according to an article in the
Atlantic if princesses like Ariel had
normal-sized eyes we might not be so
charmed by her the big guys take our
focus off Ariel's scaly fish tail and
keep it on her a lovely porcelain face
tiny chins short doses and enlarged eyes
make the characters look more like
babies which makes us fall in love with
them those eyes symbolize vulnerability
and innocence but characters with big
eyes are also seen as less smart than
their normal eyed counterparts Disney
has come under fire for perpetuating
unrealistic beauty standards a website
called above-average pointed out an
interesting fact that you may not have
noticed before
they highlighted this patch in their
photo collection of Disney Princesses
whose eyes are bigger than their
stomachs it's pretty startling to see
these pictures when you realize that
they're right there's been a lot of talk
about disproportionate bodies on Disney
Princesses it sets girls up to aspire to
standards that just start human nobody
actually looks like that the absence of
parents whether one of both parents of
Disney Princesses lose their lives or
get turned into bears or the princess
has to travel away from their parents
there seems to be a common theme all
Disney Princesses have parents who are
absent for one reason or another it
makes sense if they had to comfort
safety security and guidance of their
parents they wouldn't be able to venture
off on their own and discover who they
really are be without their parents adds
an element of danger they don't have
anyone to ask for help besides a crab or
a mentally-challenged chicken Don Hahn
the executive producer of Maleficent
shared a heartbreaking story about why
so many Disney characters are without
their mothers in the early 1940s Walt
Disney bought a house for his parents he
had the studio handyman come in and fix
the furnace in the home but apparently
the furnace leaked causing his mother to
pass away Walt's never spoke about the
passing of his mother but many thought
he believed it was his fault he must
have been haunted by it because so many
Disney films have the passing of a
parent in the stories
or maybe the male creators of most
Disney films have womb Envy look it up
it's the thing they always have happy
endings do you ever watch a Disney movie
and ask yourself what if it didn't all
magically work out in the end especially
in the older Disney Princess films
seriously Cinderella knew nothing about
Prince Charming before she married him
and rode off into the sunset
what if they found out they had nothing
in common or worse that Prince Charming
was a hoarder who couldn't hold down a
job and had a gambling problem in
Sleeping Beauty the prince kissed Aurora
while she was sleeping
yeah that's not creepy at all all they
knew about each other was that they
liked singing with squirrels in the
woods one photographer experimented with
the idea that not all princesses dreams
come true she shows an unhappy Snow
White holding a couple of babies while
one baby crawls at her feet and her
prince is just sitting there with his
feet up in a shabby suburban living room
there's one of Cinderella washing her
sorrows down at the local pub okay yeah
we can see why Disney opted for the
happily ever after thing this is just
too depressing
none of them live in modern times one
common thread of all Disney Princess
movies is that they all live in distant
periods of a long time ago and usually
in a faraway land we checked and it
seems that the most modern Disney
Princess story was The Princess and the
Frog which is set to be in the 1920s
maybe it's because olden times have a
bit more magic in them the princesses
can't just Google their way out of
messes illustrator and concept artist
Fernanda Suarez showed Cinderella with a
messy bun and a choker Mulan has short
hair modern jewelry and is wearing a
t-shirt Arial is a gorgeous freckled
face ginger with a see-through top the
artists Cape Pocahontas a haircut
stronger eyebrows and a modern shirt and
turquoise jewelry Belle is wearing a
jean jacket with a rose patch on the
shoulder messy hair and a bunch of rings
on her hands which are holding a book we
love the modern upgrade she gave to Snow
White but her Princess Jasmine is our
absolute favorite unrealistic bodies
remember when we mentioned the
unrealistic proportions of all Disney
Princesses eyes well that's not the only
unrealistic trait on these princesses
with the exception of a few princesses
such as Moana Mayor
and Mulan most Disney Princesses have
super tiny waist lines like there's no
way she still has half our ribs tiny so
what's up with the tiny waist thing
Whitney's characters be just as lovable
if they had realistic figures BuzzFeed's
Lauren Brandt's thought so look check it
out hit these princesses can breathe
while they sing now
Ariel still looks beautiful with a
normal waist else it looks even more
powerful with room for all of her ribs
under that fabulous dress
now that beast will be able to dip fell
without her snapping in half Princess
Jasmine is still as sultry as ever
Pocahontas never looked better and
Aurora will probably be able to overcome
what has to be a sleep disorder from not
being able to breathe in an incredibly
constricting corset
well done Lauren did we miss any things
that Disney Princesses have in common if
so tell us in the comments and that did
for 10 strange things all Disney
Princesses have in common
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]